* Brabbeln *
An einem solchen Ort
muss unsere dreiteilige Serie
"Reporter Spezial -
Über das ganze Leben" anfangen.
Hier fängt das Leben an.
Hier im Geburtshaus Ambra
kamen schon 600 Kinder zur Welt,
auch Olga Vonmoos'
zweiter Sohn Janusch.
Und eine solche Geburt
stellt ja das Leben der Eltern
immer etwas auf den Kopf.
Aber manchmal ist es anders,
als man sich das vorgestellt
oder gewünscht hat.
Olga Vonmoos, als Sie
am 31. März 2017 zusammen hier waren
und Janusch zur Welt kam:
In welchem Moment haben Sie gemerkt,
dass hier etwas anders ist?
Ich selber merkte es nicht.
Es war die Hebamme, die
eine Weile nach der Geburt sagte,
dass Janusch wahrscheinlich
das Downsyndrom, Trisomie 21, hat.
Und ... äh ... Erst dann.
Während der ganzen Schwangerschaft
haben wir nichts geahnt.
War das für Sie ein Schock?
Nein ... Nein.
Es war eine Unwissenheit.
Ich wusste im ersten Moment nicht,
was das bedeutete.
Viele Gedanken, die ich hatte.
Viele Bilder von ...
Aber ich verspürte trotzdem Freude.
Ich hatte einfach viele Fragen.
- Ja.
Aber hatten Sie grundsätzlich
das Gefühl,
ein gesundes Kind
zur Welt gebracht zu haben?
Total.
Ja, ich hatte die ganze Zeit
immer das Gefühl, er sei gesund,
und es sei alles gut.
Wie der Alltag
von Familie Vonmoos-Jappert aussieht,
konnten wir uns ansehen.
Wir haben euch begleitet.
Angefangen hat es eigentlich
an Januschs erstem Geburtstag.
# Zum Geburtstag viel Glück.
# Zum Geburtstag, lieber Janusch,
zum Geburtstag viel Glück.
Oh!
Bravo!
Dass Janusch heute
seinen ersten Geburtstag feiern kann,
ist nicht selbstverständlich.
Kurz nach seiner Geburt brachten ihn
nämlich ein Darmverschluss
und die darauffolgende Operation
an den Rand von Leben und Tod.
Eine häufige Komplikation
beim Downsyndrom.
Einen Monat
musste er auf der Intensivstation
des Kinderspitals beider Basel
verbringen,
bevor er nach Hause
zu Eltern und Bruder durfte.
* Sanfte Musik *
Olga Vonmoos war 30 Jahre alt,
als sie Janusch erwartete.
Im besten Alter gewissermassen.
Träumen wir zusammen?
Knapp zwei Jahre zuvor hatte sie
bereits einen Jungen geboren: Thorin.
Keinerlei Anlass also, sich während
der Schwangerschaft Sorgen zu machen.
* Sanfte Musik *
Als die Hebamme
dann kurz nach Januschs Geburt
den Verdacht äusserte,
der Kleine habe das Downsyndrom,
waren die jungen Eltern
erst einmal verunsichert.
Hast du lange geschlafen?
- Bei mir.
* Sie flüstern. *
Was, wenn das Kind behindert ist?
Weder Olga noch ihr Mann Michi
hatten sich bisher
ernsthaft mit dieser Frage
auseinandergesetzt.
Plötzlich kam in mir das Gefühl auf:
Was heisst das eigentlich?
Kann das auch heissen,
dass er Schmerzen hat
und gesundheitlich nicht ... äh ...
Dass er gesundheitlich
Probleme haben wird?
Oder was heisst das alles?
Und dann fing ich an,
mir Sorgen zu machen.
Ich kam damit nicht zurecht.
Als ich dann mit der Hebamme redete,
wir miteinander sprachen
und es hiess, dass das
nicht bedeute, dass er leide,
war die Freude umso grösser,
also die Spannung darauf, was uns
dieses Leben noch bringen würde.
Eines von weltweit 700 Babys
hat das Downsyndrom,
auch Trisomie 21 genannt.
Dabei handelt es sich
um eine Veränderung des Erbguts.
In jeder einzelnen Zelle
ist das Chromosom 21 nicht doppelt,
sondern dreifach vorhanden.
Für nichts auf der Welt
würde ich dieses Chromosom
wieder hergeben!
Das hat im Leben so viel ausgelöst.
So viel! So viel Positives.
Ja.
Gut!
Vorher war alles wie logisch.
Es würde die Schulzeit kommen,
das und jenes.
Es war wie alles aufgelöst.
Es ist so ...
Dadurch bin ich plötzlich
viel freier in den Chancen,
die wir haben.
* Sanfte Musik *
Olga Vonmoos ist Steinbildhauerin.
Heute besucht sie
den Steinbruch in Liesberg/BL.
Hier holt sie Jurakalk
für die Arbeit im Atelier.
Hallo, Beat!
- Hallo!
Welchen? Den hier?
- Ja.
Ah, ja.
Zunächst
studierte die Baselbieterin Kunst.
Aber das war ihr zu wenig konkret.
Deshalb machte sie
die vierjährige Bildhauerlehre
und stieg dann
ins Geschäft ihres Vaters ein.
Das brachte auch einen weiteren,
grossen Vorteil:
Mit den Grosseltern
in der unmittelbaren Nachbarschaft
kann sie Arbeit und Familie
optimal verbinden.
Dachten Sie daran, mit der Arbeit
aufzuhören, als die Kinder kamen?
Nein.
Nein. Das hatten wir
schon zuvor miteinander besprochen:
Wenn es überhaupt
so weit kommen sollte,
wäre es klar,
dass beide weiterarbeiten wollen.
Wir wollten auf irgendeine Art
und Weise einen Weg finden,
wie es lösbar ist.
Aber den Beruf aufgeben - nein.
Ich glaube,
dazu müsste ich gezwungen werden,
wenn es wirklich
nichts mehr zu verdienen gäbe.
* Schleifgeräusch *
Olga Vonmoos hat keine vor-
geburtlichen Untersuchungen gemacht,
obwohl seit einigen Jahren ein
einfacher Bluttest auf dem Markt ist,
der Trisomie
sehr zuverlässig erkennen kann.
Seit 2015 wird dieser
von der Krankenkasse bezahlt.
Laut Studien entscheiden sich bei
Trisomieverdacht über 90 % der Paare
für eine Abtreibung.
Das wäre für Olga und ihren Mann
nie infrage gekommen.
Man solle versuchen,
die Steine wegzuräumen,
die das Schicksal
einem in den Weg lege, findet Olga.
Und sie als Bildhauerin habe da noch
ganz andere Werkzeuge zur Verfügung.
Vielleicht,
weil ich jetzt gelernt habe,
mich an Steine heranzuwagen,
die einem in den Weg gelegt werden.
Also sie zu bearbeiten.
Aus ihnen kann man etwas machen,
das man brauchen kann,
oder etwas, das schön ist,
wenn sie einem im Weg liegen,
also vor der Nase.
Und das
war wahrscheinlich nicht immer so.
Das muss man irgendwie lernen.
Vielleicht
ist das mit Janusch noch extremer.
Noch mehr ...
In diesem Jahr hat sich
so viel in diese Richtung verändert.
Ich könnte nicht so reden,
wenn etwas schiefgegangen
oder Janusch gestorben wäre.
Oder ... äh ...
Einfach all diese schwierigen
Sachen, wenn etwas schiefgeht.
* Schleifgeräusch *
Das Jahr seit Januschs Geburt
war schwierig und sorgenvoll
und stellte die junge Familie
auf eine harte Probe.
An ihrer Liebe aber
hat Olga nie gezweifelt.
Vielleicht
wird den Leuten zu wenig gesagt,
dass man darauf vertrauen kann, dass
man das Kind, das kommt, auch liebt.
Egal, wie es ist
und wie es geboren wird.
Und das erleben Sie so?
- Mhm.
Es war auch immer klar.
Ich merke erst jetzt,
dass ich mehr Geschichten höre
von Leuten,
die es anders erleben,
damit nicht zurechtkommen oder so.
Und dann merke ich erst: "Aha!"
"Es ist nicht selbstverständlich,
dass man das so sieht
und wahrnehmen kann."
* Sanfte Musik *
Ja.
Die Kinderbetreuung
teilen sich Olga und Michi auf.
Dass sie Kinder wollten,
war ihnen bald einmal klar.
Und in grundlegenden Erziehungsfragen
sind sie sich einig.
Z.B. auch darin, dass sie
der freien Entwicklung ihrer Kinder
viel Raum geben wollen.
Wir waren nie diejenigen, die
unser Kind speziell fördern wollten
und das Ziel hatten,
dass es möglichst bald
das Gymnasium besuchen kann.
Und bei Janusch
ist es noch weniger der Fall.
Ja ... Muss es denn überhaupt
der normale Weg sein?
Oder kann es etwas total anderes ...
Also "total" ...
... etwas anderes sein?
Wie viel kann
und will man sich herausnehmen?
Mal sehen!
Das gibt noch einige Diskussionen.
Ja, wir schauen mal, wohin es geht.
Ohne Förderung geht es aber nicht.
Daniela Odermatt, eine Logopädin,
kommt auf Hausbesuch.
Ganz, ganz nahe. Komm!
Die Katze kommt auch.
Sie beobachtet, wie Janusch isst.
Jetzt. Genau. Zungendruck!
Super! Er war ganz schön.
Perfekt!
Das Ziel ist, dass die Zunge
beim Essen möglichst drin ist.
Es gibt so einen Zungenstoss,
den man verhindern möchte.
Und das gelingt,
wenn man den Druck auf die Zunge
im richtigen Moment macht.
Dadurch
lernt er das richtige Schlucken.
Sonst stösst es die Zunge.
Ja, ja.
Jetzt wird er müde.
Jetzt wird er etwas müde.
Das ist immer am Anfang.
- Ja.
Nachher wird er müde.
Genau, jetzt wird er müde.
Durch die verminderte Körperspannung
ist das sehr anstrengend.
Und da wird er halt schnell müde,
um oben zu bleiben, nicht wahr?
Nochmals!
Schau dort rüber! Schau!
- Janusch!
Schau dort rüber!
Jeder Löffel ein Kampf.
Aber aufgeben ist keine Option.
Jetzt!
- Ahm!
Genau: "Ahm!"
Du machst es gut vor.
Eben: Das hat Janusch
seit seiner Geburt bewiesen.
Er ist ein grosser Kämpfer.
Er hat enorm aufgeholt.
Als ich anfing,
war er hier einfach völlig schlaff.
Und es ist wichtig,
dass er auch andere Therapien hat -
Physiotherapie,
Frühförderung und alles Mögliche,
die alle
in dieselbe Richtung arbeiten,
dass sie unterstützend sind.
Und er hat sehr engagierte Eltern.
Sie setzen Dinge um, die man zeigt.
Und dann hat er die Chance,
einen Tonusaufbau zu machen,
weil er eben das Angebot bekommt.
Er ermüdet einfach sehr schnell.
Wie Sie sehen: zehn, zwölf Löffel
und dann wird er müde.
Man muss ihm helfen,
die Spannung hochzuhalten,
und darauf achten,
dass er durchhält.
Wichtig ist auch, dass der Becher
bis mindestens hierhin gefüllt ist.
Das hast du mir mal gesagt.
Denn sonst ...
Hier unten sind Noppen.
Sie kommen an die Lippen.
Sie geben ihm einen Impuls.
Und das Obere führt dazu,
dass er die Lippen darüberstülpt.
Jetzt käme der nächste Schritt:
Wenn die Oberlippe
die Flüssigkeit hier berührt,
wird das automatische Schlucken
ausgelöst.
Das wäre das Ziel, dass er das,
was wir selbstverständlich machen,
dann auch kann.
Ich muss gucken.
Es ist noch etwas warm.
Die Förderung von Menschen
mit Trisomie
hat grosse Fortschritte gemacht.
Auch medizinisch sind die Prognosen
heute viel besser als früher.
Die Lebenserwartung
ist in den letzten Jahrzehnten
von 20 auf 60 Jahre angestiegen.
Diejenigen, die hier sind,
sind herzlich willkommen.
Die anderen sind nicht mehr hier.
Sie sind
gar nicht zur Welt gekommen.
Es ist auch eine gewisse Toleranz.
Ich erlebe einfach,
dass heute Kinder mit Downsyndrom,
die unterstützt werden,
sozial viel weiter kommen,
besser integriert sind
und schulisch besser sind.
Ich durfte Kinder unterstützen,
die mehrsprachig sind.
Sie sind sehr lange
in die Regelschule gegangen
und haben dort
sehr gute Ziele erreicht.
Aber auch hier
gibt es riesige Unterschiede.
Das ist ein grosser Fächer.
Man kann nicht
alle Downsyndrom-Kinder,
also Trisomie-Kinder,
in denselben Topf werfen.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Janusch ist sehr herzlich willkommen,
das steht ausser Zweifel.
Seine Eltern haben sich
auf sein Tempo eingestellt.
Andere Kinder in seinem Alter
können sitzen und krabbeln,
manche können schon gehen.
Man weiss: Es dauert alles
viel länger, bis er etwas kann.
Dafür ist es umso schöner,
wenn er wieder etwas kann.
Da ist die Freude fast grösser
als bei Thorin.
Bei ihm weiss man:
Er kann das jetzt dann.
Es ist normal.
Und jetzt merkt man:
Es ist nicht einfach alles normal.
Es ist ... Ja ...
Es bereitet einem
eine riesige Freude,
wenn er wieder etwas kann.
Es stört mich gar nicht,
wenn es länger dauert.
Wir haben Zeit.
Wir haben keinen Stress,
er hat keinen Stress.
Auf Deutsch gesagt
ist es völlig egal.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Inzwischen ist es fast ein Jahr her,
seit wir bei euch zu Hause waren
und euer Familienleben mit Janusch
dokumentierten.
Was ist seither passiert?
Sehr viel. Also ...
Vieles ist einfacher geworden,
weil er mehr kann.
Er kann sich fortbewegen.
Jetzt macht er
die ersten Gehversuche.
Er kann stehen,
sich irgendwo festhalten
und fortbewegen.
Man kann ihn irgendwo hinsetzen
und er kann selber
die Gegend erkunden.
Das Essen mit ihm
geht sehr einfach.
Ja.
- Vieles ist einfacher geworden.
Er ist ...
- ... total zufrieden.
Entspannt und zufrieden.
Er ist ein sehr angenehmes Kind.
- Und so glücklich.
Ja, das macht einen
dann selbst glücklich - jeden Tag.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
ich lache viel mehr als früher,
denn es ist so ansteckend.
Es ist so ...
Es relativiert so viel, um das
du dich vorher gekümmert hast.
Jetzt ist es einfach:
Du siehst ihn an.
Er strahlt, du strahlst auch.
Fertig. Punkt.
Das sind die schönen Seiten.
Und es ist wunderbar,
dass es nach diesem schwierigen Start
viele schöne Seiten gibt.
Das hat mich sehr beeindruckt,
aber auch erstaunt.
Bei euch hat man das Gefühl:
Ihr seht das Ganze fast als Chance,
um es mal so zu sagen.
Absolut.
Aber der Moment, in dem ihr hadert
und sagt: "Warum wir?",
gab es den?
Ja, kurz, ganz am Anfang,
das muss ich sagen,
als ich gleich gesehen hatte,
dass es wahrscheinlich
ein Kind mit Downsyndrom ist,
als er zur Welt kam.
Ich sah es an seinen Augen.
Aber jetzt
eigentlich überhaupt nicht.
Nur ganz am Anfang und ganz kurz
habe ich 15 Min. lang überlegt,
wieso.
Dann sagte ich mir: "Es ist einfach
so. Es ist nichts Schlimmes."
"Wir nehmen es, wie es kommt,
und lieben es genau gleich."
Ja, das macht für uns
keinen Unterschied.
Solange er gesund ist ...
Das ist eigentlich das Wichtigste.
Und dieses Gesundsein,
also dass er immer wieder Therapien
und Untersuchungen hat,
dass er auch immer wieder
ins Krankenhaus muss,
seit er auf der Welt ist,
gehört fix zu eurem Familienleben.
Wir konnten eine
dieser Untersuchungen begleiten.
Gut!
Soll ich ihn gleich ausziehen?
Lassen Sie ihn
am besten erst mal so!
Ich würde gerne
erst kurz mit euch sprechen. Hallo!
Wie ist das so? Wie schläft er?
Also die ersten irgendwie acht,
neun Monate schlief er durch.
Beide Kinder schliefen durch.
Dann fing es an,
kompliziert zu werden.
Okay!
Gut!
Gut! Sehr gut!
Oh, er plappert aber viel!
Nimmt das mit dem Plappern
und Plaudern auch ein bisschen zu?
Gibt es verschiedene Varianten?
- Ja.
Reagiert er schon auf seinen Namen?
Haben Sie das Gefühl, er reagiert
auf seinen Namen, wenn Sie rufen?
Ja. Entweder auf die Stimme
oder den Namen.
Das ist schwer zu sagen.
- Ja, okay.
Sieh mal! Sieh mal, Janusch!
* Klingeln der Glocke *
Ist das etwas für dich?
Willst du mal schauen?
Guck mal!
Willst du nicht mal schauen?
Willst du mal schauen?
Genau, nimm sie dir mal!
Guck mal!
Willst du sie dir mal nehmen?
Gut! Bravo!
Er hantiert und arbeitet
jetzt eher mit einer Hand.
Ist das auch das, was ihr
überwiegend zu Hause beobachtet?
So dieses Bimanuelle.
- Das ist auch ein Thema.
Ja, okay!
Da!
- Da!
Er stützt sich
auch immer einseitig ab
und greift mit der anderen,
fast immer mit derselben Hand,
nach etwas.
- Okay.
Auch bei Kindern, die nicht
von Trisomie 21 betroffen sind,
also bei normal entwickelten
Kindern, ist es so,
dass sich die Händigkeit
deutlich nach dem zweiten Geburtstag
ausbildet.
Umgekehrt mögen wir es nicht, wenn
eine Händigkeit zu früh auftaucht.
So! Jetzt!
Gut!
Du hast eine schöne Körperspannung.
Das ist gut.
* Olga Vonmoos lacht. *
Gut! Und ein schönes Gewicht.
Ah, gut!
Ich wäre froh, wenn Sie ihm
die Strumpfhose ausziehen könnten.
Aber ich finde, er hat einen schönen
Muskeltonus, das muss man sagen.
Er hängt nicht
wie ein schlaffer Sack.
Das haben wir oftmals.
Oh, das mag er nicht.
- Das magst du nicht?
Ah, zack! Jawohl.
Sehr gut!
Jetzt machen wir da auch einmal auf.
Ich will mir noch
seinen Rücken ansehen,
ob er gerade ist, wenn er sitzt.
Janusch!
Gut!
Er hat einen schönen Rücken.
Er geht nicht
in einen Rundrücken rüber.
Worauf man bei den Kindern
aber aufpassen muss:
Sie können auf die Seite hin eine
Wirbelsäulenverkrümmung bekommen.
Aber er sitzt schön und
stabilisiert eigentlich ganz gut.
Das ist das Wichtige.
Isst er schon etwas vom Tisch mit,
oder ...
Nein.
- Das nicht?
Also hauptsächlich Brei?
- Ähm ... ja.
Es interessiert ihn, was es gibt,
aber er führt es nicht zum Mund.
Schaust du schnell oben?
- Ja.
Wir müssen nochmals. Komm!
Ist gut?
- Ja.
Ja. Nur 3 Sek.
- 71,2 cm.
Sieh, jetzt ist es schon wieder gut.
Und zuletzt noch etwas Erfreuliches:
Es gibt am Herzen
zwar einen kleinen Fehler,
aber sonst hat er eigentlich
keine grossen Probleme.
Macht man das nochmals?
- In einem Jahr.
Ich glaube, das Nächste ist sicher,
dass man sich darauf fokussiert,
dass er sicher und stabil
sitzen kann,
denn dann eröffnet sich für ihn
eine ganz andere Spielwelt.
Dann kann er ganz anders
am aktiven Leben teilnehmen.
Ich glaube,
das ist der nächste Punkt,
dass er das Krabbeln und Sitzen
lernt.
Das ist sicherlich eine Aufgabe
der Physiotherapie,
die Sie begleiten kann.
Deswegen finde ich es gut,
dass er das einmal pro Woche macht.
Man sollte eben auch darauf achten,
dass die Kinder
nicht übertherapiert werden.
Man muss sie auch
etwas davor schützen und sagen,
dass sie nicht mehr als zwei
Therapieformen bekommen sollen.
Von mehr
können sie noch nicht profitieren.
Und sie sollen sich auch
aus dem natürlichen Antrieb
weiterentwickeln können und nicht
nur von Therapie zu Therapie gehen.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Vieles von dem,
wie sich euer Familienleben,
aber auch Januschs Leben entwickelt,
konntet ihr nicht voraussehen.
Aber gehen wir zu dem Moment zurück,
als er noch nicht auf der Welt war.
Sie haben sich bewusst
gegen eine solche
pränatale Untersuchung entschieden.
Sie sagten, Sie machen das nicht.
Warum?
Weil ich das Gefühl habe, dass,
wenn ich während der Schwangerschaft
eine solche Untersuchung
gemacht hätte ...
Zuerst musst du dich ja fragen,
was herauskommen kann,
wenn sie diese Untersuchung
machen wollen.
Kannst du mit dem Ergebnis umgehen?
Und: Wie geht es weiter?
Geht es endlos weiter?
Machen sie dann nach
der Untersuchung mehr und noch mehr?
Und wenn ich während der
Schwangerschaft schon gewusst hätte,
dass er das Downsyndrom hat,
hätte mich das sehr verunsichert.
Also da hätte ich die
Schwangerschaft nicht mehr geniessen
und auf mein eigenes Gefühl
hören können.
Dann hätte ich, glaube ich,
einfach immer diese ...
Es ist einfach
eine Horrorvorstellung.
... Nachrichten im Kopf gehabt.
Du kannst damit nicht umgehen.
Du stellst dir Bilder vor, die
vielleicht der Wahrheit entsprechen,
vielleicht aber auch nicht.
Du versuchst, dir etwas
vorzustellen, was nicht ist.
Etwas,
das du dir nicht vorstellen kannst.
Ja.
Also völlig unnötig hätte man Hektik
in diese Schwangerschaft gebracht.
Und auf diesem Weg war es
eine sehr gute Schwangerschaft.
Von dieser
konnte auch Janusch profitieren,
von dieser guten Schwangerschaft.
Jede Energie,
die er zu sich nehmen konnte,
konnte er nachher
auf der Intensivstation gebrauchen,
habe ich das Gefühl.
Also im Nachhinein
haben Sie das Gefühl,
sind Sie eher froh,
dass Sie nicht wussten,
dass er das Downsyndrom hat.
- Ja.
Schön, oder?
* Fröhliche Musik *
Ihr Lebensentwurf hat sich für
diese Familie als richtig erwiesen.
Generationenübergreifend arbeiten,
räumliche Nähe,
welche die Integration von Familie
in den Berufsalltag zulässt.
Und unbeschwert dank Nichtwissens.
Olga und Michi haben sich bewusst
gegen pränatale Diagnostik
entschieden -
nicht zuletzt auch deshalb,
weil sie nicht durch eine Diagnose
verunsichert werden wollten.
* Fröhliche Musik *
Wie es ist, wenn man bei
einer vorgeburtlichen Untersuchung
einen schlechten Bescheid bekommt,
wissen alle drei, die jetzt bei mir
am Tisch sitzen. Herzlich willkommen!
Anna Margareta Neff ist bei uns.
Sie ist Hebamme
und Trauerbegleiterin.
Und dann haben wir ein Paar bei uns:
Vera und Oliver Sigrist.
Ihr beide
habt das im letzten Jahr erlebt.
Du warst
mit dem zweiten Kind schwanger.
Und dann, bei einer vorgeburtlichen
Untersuchung, hiess es,
dass etwas nicht stimme.
Wie war das?
Also im Moment,
als es hiess, etwas stimme nicht,
brach eine Welt zusammen.
Das war einer
der schlimmsten Momente.
Ähm ... Man erwartet es
halt irgendwie nicht,
dass es plötzlich heisst:
"Etwas ist nicht gut."
Wir haben ja schon ein Kind,
das gesund ist.
Und ... ähm ...
Ja, man geht vielleicht etwas naiv
in eine solche Untersuchung.
Und dann so etwas ...
Das war eigentlich ganz schlimm.
Wir wussten etwas mehr,
als dass etwas nicht stimmte.
Wir wussten, dass das Kind ...
... sicher eine Form
einer Kleinwüchsigkeit hat.
Ja.
Man sah, dass Arme und Beine
viel zu kurz waren.
Das wussten wir.
- Ja.
Ähm ... Mehr aber nicht.
Also nicht im Spektrum.
Ob das eine Kleinwüchsigkeit war,
die sonst keine weitere geistige
und körperliche Beeinträchtigung
mit sich bringt,
also ob das Kind gesund war,
wussten wir nicht.
Also ob es so war
oder ob es das war,
was wir schliesslich
als Diagnose hatten.
Man erlebt
eine solche Achterbahn der Gefühle.
Ich merkte auch,
dass ich mich vom Kind abnabelte.
Ich erlebte Momente,
in denen ich dachte:
"Gehe doch von dir aus!
Entscheide doch du, dass du gehst!"
Und ich wünschte mir auch,
dass die Natur uns
diesen Entscheid abnehmen würde,
damit am Schluss nicht wir in
einer Grauzone entscheiden müssen,
wenn es heisst:
"Das Kind kann das haben,
aber es muss nicht so sein."
Irgendwie hatte ich die Hoffnung,
dass es heisst:
"Es ist überlebensfähig
und es geht gut."
Oder:
"Das Kind würde sowieso sterben."
Auf der einen Seite
stellt man sich Fragen ...
... zur möglichen Lebensqualität
des Kindes.
Und auf der anderen Seite
stellt man sich selbst Fragen.
Kann man
diese Verantwortung übernehmen,
dass man ein Kind hat,
das, sagen wir mal,
in einem schlimmen Fall
oder im Extremfall
eine lebenslange Betreuung benötigt,
die keinesfalls
selber lebensfähig ist?
Kann man damit ...
Kann man damit umgehen?
Ja oder nein?
Da geht es um einen selbst.
Da geht es auch
um egoistische Fragen.
Also: Will ich mein Leben
bis zu einem gewissen Grad
eigentlich meinem Kind opfern?
Um solche Fragen geht es,
glaube ich.
Ähm ... Aber auch um Fragen wie:
Hat dieses Kind ...
... mit einer
spezifischen Beeinträchtigung ...
... denn auch eine Lebensqualität,
von der man sagen kann:
"Ja, das kann man auch verantworten"
- zumindest in einem gewissen Sinn?
Das ist dann
natürlich sehr schwierig.
Aber weil man
in dieser Ungewissheit ist,
findet man nie eine Antwort -
egal, was man sich vorstellt.
Aber das, was dabei herauskam,
bedeutete für euch:
Dieses Kind ist nicht lebensfähig.
Genau.
- Genau.
Was irgendwie natürlich ...
... in einem solchen Moment
extrem schlimm ist.
Das war ein unglaublich
schlimmer Moment, aber auch ...
Ich sagte das damals auch dem Arzt:
Es war auch eine Erleichterung,
weil wir eine klare Diagnose hatten.
Und wir mussten in diesem Sinn
auch keinen Entscheid fällen,
weil das Kind
ausserhalb des Bauches von Vera
einfach nicht überlebensfähig
gewesen wäre.
Dieser Entscheid
wurde euch am Schluss abgenommen.
Doch einen Abbruch gab es trotzdem.
- Ja, genau.
Ich wollte mir auch nicht zumuten,
ein Kind auszutragen
und zu wissen, dass es am Ende
sterben oder ersticken würde.
Die ganzen Wochen, in denen wir
nicht wussten, was los war,
waren schon genug schlimm.
Und dann noch ein Kind weiter ...
Also ich
konnte es mir nicht vorstellen,
denn ich war ja auch noch
für ein anderes Kind verantwortlich.
Man muss ja dann auch funktionieren.
Aber in einem solchen Moment
geht das nicht,
wenn man ein Kind in sich trägt und
das Gefühl hat, dass es dann stirbt.
Darum war es für uns ...
Klar mussten wir sagen:
"Wir machen das. Wir brechen
diese Schwangerschaft ab."
"Wir leiten diese Geburt ein."
Aber ... ähm ...
Ja, das war eigentlich klar.
- Ja.
In einem solchem Moment gibt es
eigentlich eine normale Geburt.
Sie wird eingeleitet. Das ist
eine Geburt wie jede andere auch.
Ich glaube,
das wissen viele Leute nicht,
dass das auch eine Geburt ist -
aber natürlich
unter ganz speziellen Vorzeichen.
Wie habt ihr das erlebt?
Ja, es war ...
... auch für mich anstrengend -
wie die erste Geburt.
Äh ... Es dauerte lange.
Von der Dauer her nicht ...
Wie lange dauerte es letztlich?
8 Std., oder?
Ja.
Obwohl er noch so klein war.
- Ähm ... Ja.
Es war ... Es war anstrengend.
Es war ...
... natürlich sehr, sehr traurig.
Aber irgendwie war es auch schön.
Es war ein wichtiger Schritt,
um vom Kind Abschied zu nehmen.
Ja.
- Ja.
Das ist etwas, was sich viele
nicht zu fragen trauen.
Dabei ist es eine wichtige Frage:
"Wie war denn diese Geburt?"
Und viele fragen: "Konntest du
keinen Kaiserschnitt machen?"
Und das ist eigentlich
der erste Gedanke, der mir auch kam:
"Nehmt das Kind raus - und weg!"
Aber ...
Es war eine wunderschöne Geburt,
obwohl ...
Es tönt irgendwie absurd,
aber ich war ihm so nahe,
wie ich ihm sonst nie sein konnte.
Und ich konnte ihm mit jeder Wehe
Tschüss sagen.
Ich hatte das Gefühl,
dass er mir sagte:
"Es ist gut, dass ich gehe."
Und ich konnte sagen:
"Es ist gut, dass du gehst."
Vito kam zur Welt
und war in dem Moment schon tot.
Aber ihr hattet ihn trotzdem
bei euch.
Genau.
Ähm ... Insgesamt
waren es fast zwei Tage, oder?
Oder ... Doch, es waren zwei Tage.
- Ja.
Ähm ...
Zwei Tage, in denen er ...
... in denen er bei uns war.
Er war bei uns im Zimmer.
Wir hatten ihn bei uns.
Er lag in einem kleinen Bett.
Ja, er bekam auch ...
... kurz Besuch von Finn
und seinen Grosseltern.
Ja, das war ...
... eine schwierige,
aber sehr wichtige Zeit.
Ja.
Anna Margareta Neff,
diese Geschichte ...
Sie haben viele andere Geschichten,
vielleicht auch ähnliche, erlebt -
als Trauerbegleiterin.
Sie leiten eine Beratungsstelle,
die Eltern unterstützt,
genau in dieser Situation.
Diese Zeit, in der man nichts weiss,
aber entscheiden muss,
stelle ich mir
unglaublich schwierig vor.
Wie kann ein Mensch
oder wie können Eltern
überhaupt
einen solchen Entscheid fällen:
Soll mein Kind zur Welt kommen
oder nicht?
Also ...
Eigentlich ist es, wie du sagst,
ein unmenschlicher Entscheid.
Eigentlich sollten die Eltern nie
über das ungeborene Leben des Kindes
entscheiden müssen.
Wenn es
ein absolutes Wunschkind ist,
ist es so sehr mit Liebe verbunden,
wie ihr auch erzählt habt.
Und dann gegen das Kind
entscheiden zu müssen,
ist etwas, das nicht geht.
Das ist wirklich unmenschlich.
Ja, und trotzdem ...
... werden viele
genau vor diese Frage gestellt:
"Was machen wir?"
Was hilft denn
in einem solchen Moment?
Was in diesem Moment das Erste ist,
was hilfreich wäre,
ist die Rückkehr zum Kind.
Und wenn das nicht passiert,
ist eigentlich ...
Ohne Kind gibt es kein Weiterleben.
Vermeintlich denkt man:
"Wir machen schnell einen Abbruch,
und dann leben wir weiter
wie vorhin."
Und dann gab es dieses Kind nie.
Und das ist etwas Vermeintliches,
das eine Strategie für die Eltern
ist.
Das ist im Moment völlig normal.
Es ist eine Notfallstrategie.
Was wir aber als Fachpersonen
wissen müssen,
ist, dass diese Notfallstrategie
nicht nachhaltig ist,
denn es gibt kein Weiterleben
ohne Kind.
Es gibt nur ein Weiterleben
mit einem verstorbenen Kind -
oder, wenn man sich
für die Schwangerschaft
und das Kind entscheidet,
ein Weiterleben mit einem
allenfalls behinderten Kind,
oder einem Kind, das bei der Geburt
oder danach sterben wird.
Wenn man den Entscheid getroffen hat
und sagt:
"Ich möchte einen Abbruch ..."
In eurem Fall war es so,
dass Vito gestorben wäre.
Aber in vielen Fällen ist es so,
dass man sagt:
"Ich möchte einen Abbruch."
Wie kann man trauern,
wenn man selber ein
schlechtes Gewissen hat und denkt:
"Ich selber habe entschieden,
dass das Kind nicht leben wird."?
Schuldgefühle sind immer dabei,
wenn ein Kind stirbt.
Wenn das eigene Kind stirbt,
das im Bauch war, überlege ich mir:
"Was habe ich falsch gemacht?"
"Warum konnte ich nicht
für das Kind sorgen?"
"Was ist passiert?"
Das ist immer dabei.
Eigentlich geht es nicht darum, dass
die Schuldgefühle nicht sein dürfen,
sondern die Fachpersonen - und das
ist mein zweites grosses Anliegen -
eine Begleitung anbieten sollen,
die kontinuierlich ist, dass man den
Eltern eine Vertrauensbasis gibt.
Und dann kann man zusammen
den Weg gehen
und auch die Schuldfrage ansprechen.
Sie können auch schauen, was sie mit
diesen Schuldgefühlen machen können.
Dieser Weg hört nicht auf,
wenn der Abbruch gemacht ist,
sondern dort fängt es an.
Viele Eltern haben das Gefühl,
wenn sie ganz schnell
durch den Prozess gehen,
könnten sie nach Hause
und alles sei wie vorher.
Aber dann fängt es erst an,
denn dann kommt das Bewusstsein,
was passiert ist.
Man sah das Kind
und hat plötzlich gemerkt:
Es ist das eigene Kind.
Für viele Eltern,
die nicht vorbereitet sind
und keine Begleitung haben,
ist es ein grosses Erstaunen,
denn sie haben entschieden:
"Ich will dieses Kind nicht."
Es war wie ein Objekt.
Und wenn es geboren ist,
also die Mutter es geboren hat,
und du als Vater siehst es,
wird es zu deinem Kind.
Das macht Eindruck.
Das war z.B. etwas, was für mich
unglaublich schlimm war.
Ich hatte all diese Hormone
und die ganze Liebe für Vito.
Diese Liebe war da.
Aber ich hatte kein Kind.
Also ich bin wie ...
Ich ging mit einem Bauch
ins Inselspital,
und kam ohne Kind raus, aber
ich hatte diese Hormone im Gepäck.
Ich meine,
ich hatte Spannungen in der Brust.
Ich hätte eigentlich
Milcheinschuss gehabt,
wie jede andere Frau auch,
wenn sie ein Kind zur Welt bringt.
Das war unglaublich.
Es war etwas vom Schlimmsten.
Es war fast noch schlimmer
als alles andere,
so im Bett zu liegen und zu wissen:
"Da gibt es kein Kind."
Das zerriss mich innerlich,
denn ich wollte mein Kind.
Da kann man nicht
einen Knopf drücken und sagen:
"Das Kind ist jetzt halt nicht da,
es lebt nicht, reiss dich zusammen!"
Man kann das
gar nicht kontrollieren.
Und das ist ...
Das ist etwas,
ich glaube, das Einzige,
bei dem es mir extrem wichtig wäre,
dass das diejenigen Frauen wissen,
die das vielleicht auch mal erleben,
dass das auf sie zukommt und
sie dann viel Unterstützung haben.
Wenn
bei vorgeburtlichen Untersuchungen
der Verdacht besteht,
dass ein Kind eine Trisomie hat,
entscheiden sich 95 % der Eltern
für einen Abbruch.
Das kommt in der Schweiz regelmässig
vor, aber niemand spricht darüber.
Ich glaube, ihr seid die Ersten, die
ich über so etwas offen reden höre.
Warum ist das ein solch grosses Tabu,
über so etwas zu reden?
Also zuerst einmal mein
grosser Respekt, dass ihr hier seid,
euch zeigt
und eure Geschichte mit uns teilt,
denn das ist absolut
nichts Selbstverständliches.
Es ist ein absolutes Tabu.
Und ich denke, es ist das grösste
Tabu, weil wir es nicht aushalten.
Es ist schon schlimm,
dass es den Tod überhaupt gibt
und Menschen sterben,
aber dass unsere Nachfolger sterben,
also die nächste Generation,
dass die Kinder sterben,
ist etwas, was mit unserem Weltbild
fast nicht vereinbar ist.
Wir halten das alle nicht aus.
Es ist auch etwas, bei dem wir uns -
gesellschaftlich bedingt -
fragen müssen:
Was machen wir mit
den vorgeburtlichen Untersuchungen?
Es ist ein Eingriff
ins Mutter- und ins Vatersein
und natürlich ein Rieseneingriff
fürs Kind.
Das heisst nicht,
dass ich es verteufeln möchte,
aber ich glaube,
es ist ganz wichtig,
dass wir uns als Gesellschaft
wirklich Gedanken machen,
welche Bedeutung die
vorgeburtlichen Untersuchungen haben
und welche Konsequenzen.
Und trotzdem ... Also ich höre:
Ihr wärt wieder bereit
für ein zweites Baby.
Mhm.
Habt ihr schon entschieden, ob ihr
wieder pränatale Diagnostik macht?
Ich glaube, es erübrigt sich -
schon nur ...
... weil es für mich
der einzige Weg wäre, um zu sehen,
dass eine Schwangerschaft
intakt ist,
solange ich das Kind nicht spüre.
Also schon nur,
um einen Ultraschall zu machen.
Wenn ich schon wissen kann,
dass mein Kind vielleicht
eine Beeinträchtigung hat,
habe ich wenigstens die Chance,
mich darauf einzustellen
und diesem Kind
einen Start zu gewährleisten,
weil ich über die Krankheit,
über die Beeinträchtigung
schon viel weiss.
Ich bin schon fast aufgefangen
und habe irgendwie eine Basis.
Also ich denke,
es ist sehr zu respektieren,
was du für dein Leben
oder für euer Leben machen würdest
oder mit dieser Erfahrung
weitergehst.
Ich erlebe es z.T. auch anders:
nämlich, dass Eltern,
nachdem sie eine solche Erfahrung
wie ihr gemacht haben, auch sagen:
"Beim nächsten Kind
machen wir nichts mehr."
"Wir wurden so geprägt
und waren nicht mehr in Beziehung
mit dem Kind."
"Wir sind in der Schwangerschaft
zusammen mit dem Kind unterwegs,
und dann soll passieren,
was passiert."
"Wir schauen bei der Geburt,
was nachher ist."
Ich glaube,
das ist ein grosses Spannungsfeld.
Einerseits will man ja irgendwie ...
Also man will natürlich
irgendwelche Informationen.
Aber man will natürlich
keine solchen Negativinformationen.
Man will eigentlich die Bestätigung
haben, dass alles gut ist.
Genau.
Mit Risiken kann man irgendwie
gar nicht richtig umgehen,
zumindest ich nicht. Es ist irgend-
wie schwierig, das einzuordnen.
Es ist nicht fassbar.
- Ja.
Danke vielmals,
dass ihr hier gewesen seid,
Vera und Oliver Sigrist!
Ein Dank auch an Anna Margareta Neff!
Alles Gute für euch!
Danke gleichfalls!
- Vielen Dank!
Wir lernen in dieser Sendung
noch eine dritte Familie kennen:
die Familie Janouschek.
Sie hatte schon einen Jungen
und bekam dann ein Zwillingspaar -
zwei Mädchen.
Das eine Mädchen war kerngesund,
das andere unheilbar krank.
* Sanfte Musik *
Jara und ihre
eineiige Zwillingsschwester Jael.
Ein Herz und eine Seele.
* Sanfte Musik *
Janis ist der grosse Bruder im Bund.
Sie will einen Apfel.
- Oder einen Apfel.
Jara kann sich nicht bewegen,
weder sprechen noch selber essen.
Sie bekam vor der Geburt
zu wenig Sauerstoff.
Ihr Hirn wurde dabei
fast vollständig zerstört.
Dass Jara so schwer behindert ist,
zeigte keine
vorgeburtliche Untersuchung an.
Also es tat sich ein Abgrund auf,
ja.
Aber ich hatte
noch einen Funken Hoffnung,
dass es nicht so schlimm ist.
Es blieb bei der Hoffnung.
Die Eltern nahmen das Mädchen nach
der Geburt nach Hause zum Sterben.
Jara trank überraschend an der Brust,
wollte leben.
So, mein Schätzchen! Ist gut?
In meiner Welt ist sie schon
etwa sechs-, siebenmal gestorben.
Sie war grau, atmete nicht mehr -
und dann kam sie wieder,
hatte rosa Wangen
und war wieder ganz die Alte.
Es tönt.
Heute wird abgeklärt, ob Jara
eine Medikamentenpumpe erhalten soll,
die direkt
in den Bauch implantiert wird.
Das ist diese Pumpe,
die sie bekommt.
Die Wirkung ist nach wie vor ...
Also ...
Die Pumpe soll Schmerzmittel direkt
in den Rückenmarkskanal abgeben,
abgestimmt auf Jaras Bedürfnisse.
Also das sehen wir dann nachher.
Als wir im Notfall waren,
merkte man,
dass die Spastik
Probleme in den Hüften verursacht.
Und die Hüfte verursacht Schmerzen.
Und diese
fördern wiederum die Spastik.
Und dann sind wir im Kreislauf drin.
Diesen
können wir nicht durchbrechen.
Wir sind
mit den Medikamenten ausgeschöpft.
Wenn es bei ihr kritisch wird,
wollen wir ihr nicht zumuten,
über lange Zeit lebenserhaltende
Massnahmen zu ergreifen.
Für uns ist es einfach so:
Sie ist bei uns, solange sie will.
Aber wenn ihr Körper nicht mehr mag,
darf sie gehen.
Das ist jetzt Spastik
und Dystonie gemischt.
Und dann kann man sie
einfach fast nicht anziehen.
Man hat dann das Gefühl,
man müsse ihr den Arm brechen,
um hineinzukommen. Das ist ...
Das ist nicht gut.
Aber sie kann mir nicht sagen:
"Mami, ich habe das und das."
Das macht einen so ohnmächtig!
Das macht einen wirklich ohnmächtig.
Warum jetzt
diese Medikamente vorbereiten?
Einfach, weil ich im Moment
nicht aus dem Haus gehe,
ohne etwas dabeizuhaben.
Jaga? Die da?
Heisst die Jaga?
Oder Jara?
Und einmal mehr hilft die
Lebensfreude der gesunden Schwester,
der Krise zu trotzen.
- Schauen, hören, gehen!
Heute wird Jara operiert.
Endlich können die Ärzte
die Medikamentenpumpe implantieren.
Jetzt wäre ich froh, wenn Sie ...
Hast du zwei?
Nein? Gut!
Du kannst mal daran riechen.
Ist das gut?
Ja.
Jetzt kommt es gut.
- Ja.
Ja.
- Okay!
Hi, Jara!
Nein, Schatz,
Jara ist noch in der Narkose.
Jara schläft noch.
Jara ist noch nicht bei uns -
leider.
Sie ist immer noch in der Operation.
* Stimmengewirr *
Jael!
- Darf ich das Telefon haben?
Die Schwierigkeit ist einfach,
wenn ich sehe,
wie Nicole am Limit ist.
Ihre Reaktionen, ihre ...
... Bitten: "Kommt!"
Aber es geht nicht.
Und ...
Das belastet mich, weil mir auch
die Hände gebunden sind.
Und ...
... ich weiss einfach nicht,
wie es weitergeht.
Wenn es keine Veränderung gibt,
müssen wir irgendwann mal
eine Massnahme finden und sagen:
"Jetzt müssen wir einen radikalen
Wechsel irgendeiner Art machen."
Sonst erträgt das die Familie nicht.
Entweder geht es mit der Ehe
nicht mehr weiter oder ...
Weil einfach alles belastet ist.
Ich meine, ich bin diejenige,
die motzt und Dinge anspricht.
Doch dann ist es draussen,
und ich habe es gesagt.
Das bedeutet nicht,
dass er ein schlechter Mann ist
oder die Beziehung schlecht ist.
30 Min.? Gut.
Ungefähr. Vielen Dank!
Auf Wiederhören!
Also: Es dauert etwa noch 30 Min.
Er ist fertig.
Okay!
Es sei alles wunschgemäss verlaufen.
- Sehr gut!
Ich bin sehr froh.
Jetzt fällt schon eine Last ab, oder?
- Ja.
Ja.
Ich könnte weinen,
aber ich mache es nicht.
Einfach diese Anspannung.
Es war eine solch krasse Spannung.
Dann die Frage:
"Kann man sie operieren? Nicht?"
Dann: "Ja, sie ist wieder gesund."
Dann ... Ja, einfach ...
Eben, so diese Hoffnung,
dass es jetzt besser wird.
Es wird besser -
zumindest vorübergehend.
Familie Janouschek
verreist in die Skiferien.
Schau! Heb die Beine hoch!
Jetzt können wir die Tür nicht mehr
öffnen, bis wir dort sind.
Wieso nicht?
- Sonst fallen die Skier raus.
Ja, das ist jetzt einfach so.
- Aber das ist ja kein Problem.
Du gibst noch rasch die Medikamente,
oder?
Das Wetter könnte schöner nicht sein.
Schlitteln mit Jara.
Jetzt geht es dann los, Jara.
Ihr gebt mit Jara schon ziemlich Gas.
Das ist so der Klassiker:
Die Palliativmediziner würden sagen:
"Juhu, am Leben!
Lebensqualität geben!"
Und der Orthopäde würde sagen:
"Spinnt ihr?"
Aber so ist es. Also ...
Genau, wir machen jetzt das,
von dem wir finden, es sei richtig.
Und das ist momentan wirklich,
dem Leben Qualität zu geben.
* Sanfte Musik *
Schön! Hey, Jara! Super!
So!
- Ade!
Ja, ja, ja!
Diese Bilder
von der Familie Janouschek
entstanden vor gut einem Jahr.
Nicole Janouschek,
wie geht es Jara heute?
Momentan geht es ihr sehr, sehr gut.
Ja.
- Also es ist ... äh ...
... sehr unterschiedlich.
Der März beispielsweise
war ein ganz, ganz schlechter Monat.
Was heisst das?
- Äh ... Sie wäre fast gestorben.
Sie hatte
eine ganz schwere Lungenentzündung.
Sie war vier Tage lang
im Krankenhaus und ... ähm ...
Sie bekam zwei Wochen lang
ein Antibiotikum.
Ähm ...
Wir lagen im Clinch:
Sollten wir ins Krankenhaus fahren
oder sie zu Hause lassen
und es bis zum bitteren Ende
durchziehen?
Also ...
Ob ihr sie sterben lassen solltet?
- Ja, genau.
Also diese Diskussion
oder auch schwierige Entscheidung,
ob man lebensverlängernde Massnahmen
einsetzen soll oder nicht,
ist in dem Fall immer noch akut?
- Ja, nicht immer gleich akut,
aber ich glaube,
diese Diskussion bleibt wirklich,
bis sie stirbt.
- Ja.
Also da muss man sich
leider nichts vormachen.
Sie bleibt, bis sie stirbt.
- Ja.
Aber jetzt haben Sie vorhin gesagt,
es gehe ihr gut.
Ja.
Es geht ihr wirklich so gut
wie schon ganz lange nicht mehr.
Also sie lacht. Sie ist zufrieden.
Sie ist voll dabei.
Ähm ... Wir haben
seit letztem Dezember Travis,
einen Epidog.
- Einen Epidog?
Genau.
Also das ist eine
der grossen Neuerungen.
Das ist der Epidog.
Er bereichert unser Leben extrem
und hilft uns dabei,
mit ihrer schweren Behinderung
umzugehen.
Was macht ein Epidog?
Ein Epidog
macht eigentlich ganz viel.
Er ... ähm ...
reduziert die Anfälle.
Er verhindert die Anfälle.
Er zeigt sie an.
Er zeigt die Sauerstoffsättigungs-
abfälle an. Er zeigt Fieber an.
Wie kann er das machen?
Indem er Jara nahe ist?
Oder wie zeigt er das an?
Wie geht das?
Indem er ihr die Socke auszieht
oder versucht,
ihr die Orthese auszuziehen,
wenn sie auffiebert.
Er leckt auch bestimmte Stellen ab,
v.a. im Gesicht.
Während des Anfalls.
Dann werden Hormone ausgeschüttet,
sodass sie herausfindet
oder mit weniger Medikamenten
daraus herausfindet.
Er checkt jeden Morgen,
während sie noch schläft,
wie sie riecht
und wie ihr Tonus ist.
Je nachdem handelt er dann.
Wenn er von Jara weggeht,
weiss ich, dass alles okay ist.
Dann kann ich auch entspannen.
Das ist eine der grossen Neuerungen
in Ihrem Leben,
die auch wieder vieles
einfacher gemacht hat, glaube ich.
Ja.
- Der Epidog Travis. Aber sonst ...
Einfach mal so gefragt,
Nicole Janouschek:
Hat Jara ein Leben,
das Sie als lebenswert bezeichnen?
Jein. Ich muss ganz klar Jein sagen.
- Ja.
Wenn es ihr gut geht,
wenn sie keine Lungenentzündung hat,
wenn sie ...
... keine Schmerzen
von den Gelenken, dem Rücken,
den Hüften her
oder was auch immer hat:
Ja.
Das tönt zwar ganz extrem,
weil sie sonst
wirklich schwerstbehindert ist.
Aber ich muss sagen:
Ja, sie lebt gerne,
denn sonst hätte ihr Körper
ja längst aufgegeben.
Ja.
Wenn sie aber leidet, wie
bei dieser Lungenentzündung im März,
oder wenn sie wegen des Anti-
biotikums schlimmen Durchfall hat,
muss ich ganz klar sagen:
Was soll das?
Und dann muss ich sagen: Nein.
Dann muss ich sagen: Nein. Nein.
Und wir haben die Hoffnung,
dass, wenn sie nicht mehr kann ...
... dass sie dann wie ...
... dass sie dann gehen kann.
Aber das ist
natürlich auch extrem naiv.
Warum?
Weil sie einfach
so eine Kampfsau ist.
Weil sie einfach nicht aufgibt.
Weil ich mir nicht vorstellen kann,
dass sie schön einschlafen kann,
leider, obwohl ich mir das mit
jeder Faser meines Körpers wünsche.
Wenn wir spazieren gehen,
denke ich manchmal:
"Schlafe doch einfach ein!
Und ich merke es erst zu Hause."
Und dann
kann ich nichts mehr machen.
Dann ist es klar:
Sie hat bei etwas, was sie liebt,
nämlich beim Spazierenfahren,
einfach gehen können.
- Ja.
Nicole Janouschek,
wenn Sie mir das so sagen, weiss ich:
Ganz viele Leute,
die jetzt zusehen, denken:
"Das kann nicht sein, dass eine
Mutter ihrem eigenen Kind wünscht,
dass es sterben kann,
gehen darf und sein lassen kann."
Wie kommt man an diesen Punkt,
an dem Sie sind?
Ähm ...
Wie kommt man an diesen Punkt?
Wir haben so wenig erwartet.
Und sie hat schon
so viel länger gelebt,
als irgendwie alle dachten.
- Mhm.
Daher finden wir,
dass sie nichts mehr muss.
Und wieso ... Ich habe das Gefühl:
"Jetzt musst du für uns
nicht mehr kämpfen."
"Jetzt sind wir doch
ganz viele Schritte weiter."
Ich kann diese Frage nicht
wirklich beantworten, merke ich.
Es ist extrem schwierig.
Wir sind einfach
schon durch viel Schlimmes gegangen,
dass wir wünschen, dass sie es jetzt
einfach schön haben kann.
Wie ist das? Wir haben jetzt von ganz
vielen verschiedenen Familien gehört,
wie sie mit dieser Pränataldiagnostik
umgehen.
Die einen hatten eine Diagnose
und entschieden sich dazu,
die Schwangerschaft abzubrechen.
Die anderen sagten: "Ich bin froh,
dass ich es nicht wusste
und es nicht entscheiden musste."
Sie wussten es auch nicht.
Sie bekamen Zwillinge.
Das eine Mädchen war gesund,
das andere, Jara, schwerstbehindert.
Wären Sie froh gewesen,
Sie hätten es gewusst
und hätten
diese Pränataldiagnostik gehabt,
mit der Sie hätten entscheiden
können, was passieren soll?
Ich glaube nicht. Ich ...
Na ja, es geht dann immer darum,
was man auch
den anderen Kindern sagt.
Also wie kann ich das verantworten,
dass ich ihrer
eineiigen Zwillingsschwester sage,
dass sie kein Recht aufs Leben hat,
weil sie schwer behindert ist?
Aber wenn ihr mal etwas passiert -
und wie vielen Kindern passiert et-
was, weil sie vor ein Auto rennen -
kann ich sie ja
auch nicht einfach töten.
Also es ist so ... Oder?
- Ja.
Wie rechtfertigst du das
vor dir selbst,
ohne dass ich das jetzt ...
Ich kann nicht entscheiden,
wie andere Leute
in dieser Situation entscheiden.
Ich bin nicht gegen Abtreibung.
Jede darf das so entscheiden,
wie es für sie oder das Paar stimmt.
Also ein Mensch, der alle
Möglichkeiten hat, ist akzeptiert,
und ein Mensch,
der fast keine Möglichkeiten hat,
ist nicht akzeptiert. Das kann ich
fast nicht rechtfertigen.
Darum bin ich auch wirklich froh,
dass man nichts sah.
Ich musste alle zwei Wochen
zur Untersuchung.
Und letztlich war alles gut -
bis auf den Schluss.
Und ... ja.
Eine solch schwere Behinderung,
wie sie Jara hat,
betrifft nicht nur sie selbst,
sondern die ganze Familie.
Was macht das mit einer Familie
und einer Beziehung?
Hm!
Es schwankt auch ganz extrem.
Was es mit mir macht:
Momentan bin ich so auf Kampf aus.
Ausbruch, Kampf.
Aber das ist
eine ganz krasse Momentaufnahme.
Also weg
von dieser blöden Opferrolle,
von der ich momentan
einfach genug habe.
So: "Oh, die Arme!"
Und:
"Ihr habt keine Zeit mehr für euch!"
Ja, das hat man auch nicht,
wenn man gesunde Kinder hat.
Wie ist es denn mit Jara und Jael?
Was haben sie ...
Welche Beziehung hat Jael
zu ihrer Zwillingsschwester?
Sie machen es - auch Janis -
wirklich gigantisch!
Ich behaupte jetzt mal:
Für Jara sind ihre Geschwister
die Wichtigsten.
Das ist einfach das Normale.
Das ist das Lustige,
das Streiten ...
Sie lacht auch immer,
wenn sich die beiden zanken.
Sie teilen wirklich aus,
und das findet sie am lustigsten.
Dann denke ich: "Wenigstens jemand,
der das lustig findet."
Jael sagt immer,
sie habe mit ihrer Zwillings-
schwester eine Geheimsprache.
Und das glaube ich ihr auch.
Oder auch, dass Janis
bei einer Bahn vorprescht und sagt:
"Meine Schwester ist schwerstbe-
hindert. Muss ich dennoch anstehen?"
Sie gehen einfach ...
Sie gehen einfach damit um ...
- ... wie Kinder mit etwas umgehen.
Genau.
Sie schauen,
dass es möglichst viel bringt.
Genau.
- Wofür sind Sie dankbar?
Für die Leute, die geblieben sind,
und die Leute,
die wir wegen Jara
kennengelernt haben. Ähm ...
Und ...
Ja, schon auch für diese Liebe.
Die ist so ...
Das tönt so kitschig
und abgedroschen,
doch diese Liebe,
die Jara einem geben kann,
das ist von einem anderen Planeten.
Das ist einfach anders.
Wenn man so das Bedürfnis hat ...
Halten. Kuscheln.
Und wenn ich finde,
dass es wieder Zeit dafür ist,
gehe ich einfach zu Jara.
Dann kann die Welt
nebenan untergehen.
Die können nebenan toben.
Es ist mir egal, ich bin bei Jara.
Und mein Mann
hat das lustigerweise auch.
Das sind die schönen Situationen
und Gefühle.
Also ich wünsche Ihnen sehr,
dass es von diesen Momenten
in Ihrem Leben mit Jara
noch sehr viele geben wird.
Alles Gute für Ihre Familie!
Vielen Dank, Nicole Janouschek!
Danke!
Und von Nicole Janouschek
gehen wir nochmals zu Janusch zurück.
Sie erinnern sich sicher:
Das ist der kleine Junge,
den wir zu Beginn der Sendung
kennengelernt haben.
Seine Eltern Olga und Michi
sagen etwas ganz Ähnliches,
wie Nicole Janouschek gesagt hat.
Sie sagen:
"Dank Janusch ist für uns
eine andere Welt aufgegangen."
"Eine, die wir so
vorher nicht gekannt haben."
"Eben auch dank Menschen, die wir nur
dank Janusch kennengelernt haben."
Hallo!
- Hallo, Gaby!
Der Familientreff in Binningen/BL.
Einmal im Monat
gibt es hier ein Stelldichein
für Familien
mit Kindern mit Downsyndrom.
Der Moment,
als das Kind zur Welt kam,
ist für alle
noch in lebhafter Erinnerung.
* Sanfte Musik *
Nein.
Es war total überraschend.
Bei der Geburt hat der Arzt gesagt:
"Ihr Kind hat Trisomie 21."
Wir wussten nicht, was das hiess.
Zu Beginn war es sehr schwierig.
Ich konnte es nicht akzeptieren.
Aber nach zwei, drei Monaten
hatte ich mich daran gewöhnt.
Gleiche Sorgen, gleiche Freuden
und gleiche Erfahrungen.
Du siehst ihnen die Unsicherheit
gleich in den Augen an.
Ich nehme es ihnen nicht übel,
aber ...
Nein, ich glaube,
ich hätte auch so reagiert.
Wir machten
eine Nackenfaltenmessung.
Diese war unauffällig. Da
machten wir uns keine Gedanken mehr.
Sie wäre so oder so
willkommen gewesen.
Wir haben es schon
in der Schwangerschaft erfahren.
Wir machten einen Pränataltest.
Wir wussten es schon
in der 19. Schwangerschaftswoche.
Am Anfang war es sicher ein Schock,
aber dann nahmen wir es so,
wie es kam. Jetzt ist es so.
Was, wenn das Kind behindert ist?
Über diese Frage mussten sich hier
alle Gedanken machen.
Ihre Antwort
scheinen sie gefunden zu haben.
Und in unserer nächsten Sendung
von "Reporter Spezial"
gehen wir ins mittlere Lebensalter -
dann, wenn die Kinder
schon etwas grösser sind
und die Beziehung
wieder mehr ins Zentrum rückt.
Dann, wenn man sich fragt:
"Möchte ich mit dem
ein Leben lang weiterleben
oder braucht es etwas Neues?"
Bis dann!